to brazil now where more than 10 percent
of the world's largest wetlands the
pantenal
have been devastated this year by
unprecedented fires
those fighting the blazes can only hope
that enough rain comes soon
to help extinguish the flames but it's
more than just the hot dry conditions
that stand in the way
of protecting this region as we find out
in our next report
for the past several weeks catastrophic
forest fires have ravaged the panatl
nature reserve
destroying a unique ecosystem in the
process
the director of the reserve has watched
helplessly as more of the protected
landscape burns each day
last year alone 10 000 hectares of
forest burnt to the ground
this year it's been three times that
much it's a huge loss
this area is one of the most biodiverse
places in the world
tourists flock here to see endangered
animals in the wild
like the jar of stork and jaguars
these are the worst fires the area has
seen in over a decade
further north fires are also raging in
the amazon rainforest
many of them were started illegally to
clear forest for farming
the smoke from those fires has spread to
cities with devastating consequences for
the health of locals
but farmers know there are few
consequences for illegally starting the
fires brazil's president jair bolsonaro
consistently undermines protections
ngos get money from abroad and they
don't have a chance of fighting me
i will continue to fight and kill this
cancerous tumor that is the
environmental protection agency
bolsonaro dispatched the military to the
amazon to help battle the fires
the same military that carved roads
through it and erected settlements
during the military dictatorship from
1964
to 1985. critics fear brazil's military
could create a permanent presence in the
rainforest
no no there will be no militarization of
the rainforest we're just here in a
logistical capacity
for example our helicopters they're used
to battle the fires
it's likely after the fires agriculture
here will expand
including more fields for products like
soybeans and meat bound for the european
market
that's why environmentalists are calling
for eu laws that would protect brazil
against further deforestation
every day the flames reach further the
area is in dire need of rain
but none is expected for at least
several weeks